What is your advice for finding a sane
sound therapist and do you think a
fruitful psychotherapeutic relationship
requires a therapist to have specific
temperamental compatibility or even
literacy and interests that align with
the patient?
Well,
I would say with regards to finding a
sane and sound therapists there some
practical things you can do.
Um,
I guess this is more relevant if you
live in North America and I'm not sure
exactly what the training requirements
are in other places in the world,
but your best bet I would say is to find
someone who is appropriately trained and
I would regard someone who's
appropriately trained as a
psychotherapist to be someone who's.
I think you're safer if you go with
someone who's trained at one of the big
research schools and you have a
therapist who's well versed in
psychotherapeutic practice but who's
also sufficiently educated
scientifically to be able to understand
the scientific literature and you can be
pretty certain of that.
If you find a therapist who's got their
phd rather than us id.
Not that there's anything necessarily
wrong with ids.
If they had received their phd from an
American Psychological Association,
Approved School of Clinical Psychology,
and those schools operate under what's
called the bolder model,
and the boulder model is promotes,
um,
science,
science practitioner as,
as the optimal ideal combination for a
psychotherapist.
So someone who's trained,
psychotherapeutic,
but also has research experience and can
understand the relevant scientific
literature as it pertains to,
to mental health.
So that would be the first thing.
The second thing I would say is,
um,
well go to see a psychotherapist once
and maybe go to see a couple of them and
find someone that listens to you because
the psychotherapist shouldn't be someone
who solves your problems for you or
offers even really offers you advice.
Although sometimes that can be helpful.
Really what the psychotherapists should
do is be someone who can help you
understand what problem it is that
you're facing so that that can be
delineated properly to help you
articulate what it is that you want.
So what your vision of mental health
might be in,
and what you'd like to attain in
psychotherapy.
And then who helps you strategize
towards that end.
And so you want someone who will really
listen to you,
that you feel comfortable telling the
truth too,
because that's also incredibly
important.
If you can't tell you a psychotherapist
the truth,
then you're not going to get anywhere
therapy because you won't be able to
actually outline the nature of your
fundamental problems.
So that's vital.
And go see someone and see if you're
happy with the way that you're
interacting with them.
That's the most relevant issue.
So that's the first question.
Now the next one was,
do I think a fruitful psychotherapeutic
relationship requires the therapists to
have specific,
temperamental compatibility or even
literacy and interests that align with
the patient.
I think it's difficult to work with the
therapist who is less intelligent than
you are.
That's kind of a rough way of
conceptualizing it,
but a lot of what a therapist does is
help you strategize and the person has
to be able to think analytically and
probably at least to some degree,
to the same with the same degree of
complexity that you're capable of.
It's not necessarily a good idea to be
able to think your,
your therapist.
So was there ever a time when you saw a
therapist of some kind.